foreign
[Music]
okay it's kind of hard to believe but
yeah this is a real product what I'm
holding is the new Dyson Zone air
purifying headphones that's exactly what
they're called you can look it up so
when this first started popping up on
actual like Dyson social media channels
I had to double check the calendar to
make sure it wasn't April 1st because
seriously Dyson are you pranking us
right now this is It's a thousand
dollars
for air purifying headphones I wasn't
really sure what to think probably safe
to ignore it
but then one by one videos started
popping up on YouTube on Twitter on
Instagram and people actually started
asking like hey Marquez can you check
out those Dyson headphones can you check
out the Dyson zone so that look you see
here is me realizing I just spent a
thousand dollars plus shipping on
something that I already believe is a
terrible product but I'm still here to
do my job and find out anyway but here's
the thing and probably the weirdest part
and most important part of this whole
thing
Dyson this product could only have come
from Dyson it it makes no sense but
makes all the sense in the world so
ignoring the whole embarrassing social
media campaign around the vacuums for a
second like I love my Dyson vacuum
cleaner right A lot of people I know
have bought Dyson vacuums No Regrets We
love these things they're great and then
over the years Dyson has built up like a
cult following and loyal fan base over
what is basically
Motors and filtration like Dyson is a
Motors and filtration company and
they've built that out and turned it
into some of the most amazing vacuum
cleaners in the world and they're also
some of the most expensive like
seriously if you want a stick vacuum you
can just get one on Amazon for like a
hundred bucks easy but then you kind of
get the feeling that Dyson is the brand
name that they're all copying but
naturally you don't stop there right
you're successful with one thing but you
got to Branch out so what else do you do
you've all seen the Dyson bladeless fan
thing right I mean this is almost a
legendary product on its own the Dyson
fan slash air purifier in the corner of
the room of a 500 a night Airbnb do
other companies make bladeless fans now
sure but people want the Dyson one the
700 Dyson one another successful
implementation of Motors infiltration
there's also the Dyson hair dryer
another cult classic this thing is
absolutely incredible I don't even use a
hair dryer I actually use this thing to
heat up the dbrand Skins to put on the
back of my phones and it's awesome for
that too another successful
implementation of Motors infiltration so
Dyson is no stranger to charging a lot
of money successfully for a seemingly
Niche product but that doesn't mean they
can't miss you guys have probably heard
about maybe you haven't they made a
floor lamp too
maybe you haven't heard about it because
it's less successful it's also 850 so
they can miss you also might have heard
about the car prototype that they
brought to CES which like okay yes you
make Motors and motors are one part of
an electric car but there are lots of
other parts of a car that are really
hard and trust me a Dyson car is kind of
a tough sell no matter what you're going
to price it at so Dyson has a lot of
hits and some complete misses
so what's this one going to be
okay so this product is part headphones
part air purifier
I know about headphones so let's talk
about the headphones part first and
these headphones are absolutely wild
first of all
they're gigantic like they're absolutely
huge I don't even have to tell you that
now a lot of the size will make more
sense when we get to the filtration part
and everything that's also inside these
ear cups later but just as a pair of
headphones on your head these things are
huge they stick out a lot to this side
but honestly it's mostly the weight okay
so Audio Technica is M50 so I've talked
about those in the past very familiar
headphones totally normal
288 grams
not that bad on your head then you get
to like the heaviest headphones we
talked about how heavy airpods Max are
those are 388 grams which is a lot
these are
588 grams so it feels like I'm wearing a
football helmet these things are so
heavy now there's a lot of metal but
they do try to maximize comfort with
these really soft cushions and the ear
cups are super soft and the top of the
headphones are soft and then it's this
purple velvet color the side pieces are
more for stability to keep them in place
on your head and honestly if you're just
sitting in one place not moving around
too much listening to music in a chair
or on a train or something I guess then
they're not terrible it's just the
second you start moving around or
looking up and down or walking that you
really feel the weight it seriously
feels like a helmet material wise though
it is nothing but the premium materials
I gotta say the headphone band is metal
the cushions are super soft the ear cups
are metal through and through you can
see the microphones very clearly around
the bottom the USBC port and the
controls are actually very very clever
everything is on the right ear cup and
it's mostly by this little joystick here
so instead of trying to swipe on a
finicky touch surface or something like
that you literally tap up and down on
the joystick for volume tap left or
right for the next track and previous
track and amazingly you can actually
hold down the joystick to the right or
left to scrub forward or backward in
whatever audio you're in and it worked
in a bunch of apps for me too to my
surprise worked in apple music worked in
Spotify my podcast app it didn't work in
YouTube or SoundCloud but even yeah just
the thought of being able to fast
forward a little bit to the middle of a
podcast or something on Spotify is kind
of sick I've never seen that before but
of course with the super high price tag
you hopefully care about how they sound
so how do these sound big premium
expensive active noise cancellation 40
millimeter drivers how did these do they
sound as high-end as they cost
no they don't but they sound okay I mean
they sound like some two to three
hundred dollar headphones that I've
heard even though they're built like 400
headphones but I'll say the sound
overall is pretty balanced and
reasonably Bassy and Punchy in the low
end there's a pretty good passive seal
with these ear cups and then the active
noise cancellation does a little extra
work for you it is just a Bluetooth
headphone there's no wired connection
and nothing fancy as far as lossless
audio or special codecs or anything like
that but you know they sound crisp with
a little extra brightness in the highs
what's more impressive is so the active
noise cancellation is pretty good but
the transparency mode is actually
excellent this is the best I've heard
from anything that isn't airpods and you
can double tap the right ear cup to
switch between transparency mode and
noise cancellation the battery life of
these is about 50 hours which is right
at the top of its class where noise
cancellation headphones with ANC on
um they also don't have an on off switch
so they do on head detection kind of
like airpods Max so when you take them
off your head they go into this I title
mode and you put them back on they play
this nice chime they turn back on and
now you're listening to music again
ergonomically they're not anything
special but we know the joystick for the
controls the transparency mode
these are pretty good headphones
so that brings us to part two so like I
said this is a two in one product part
headphones part air purifier let's just
completely ignore the why for a second
just so we can just understand what's
happening and how this works so these
headphones come with this little plastic
visor thing so inside the ear cups of
the headphones you can pop off the
outside cover and that's where these
filters go that came in the box and
those filters are covering these air
intakes and Tiny micro compressors that
suck in the air from the outside world
these filters help purify the air by
cutting down 99 of pollutants as small
as 0.1 microns then they pass that clean
air through these slots the visor
connects the headphones via magnets to
these slots and creates a seal so that
the air is channeled down through it and
passes over your nose and mouth through
the mesh at the front it is a pretty
intricate setup but the idea is pretty
straightforward basically like oh okay
you've got noise pollution noise
canceling headphones gotcha cover oh
you've got air pollution too
fresh air all the time we got you
covered now the timing of these was
actually super unfortunate because
contrary to what you might be thinking
right now this has nothing to do with
the pandemic nothing to do with covet it
happened to be announced right around
the same time
um but this is really directly
advertised that people who live in or
commute in cities with bad air quality
dust pollen smog gas fumes grass
clippings whatever it is just bad air
quality so the idea is you're about to
go out on your commute with the polluted
world around you so you put the
headphones on you snap the visor on and
now you're uh you're getting the fresh
air the entire time you're outside with
these fans spinning
it's the idea anyway now I went through
the painful exercise of going out and
testing these things so you don't have
to okay so I'm looking kind of
ridiculous on public streets because hey
I want to see if this will actually work
I walked past roadways to see if I could
smell gasoline I walked past Landscaping
to see if I could smell pollen and lawn
clippings I walked into a public Porta
John to see if I could survive you know
and uh bad news I could still smell a
lot of everything I mean there was a
nice little stream of fresh air going
over my nose and mouth it's a nice
little breeze but yeah you can still
smell everything I think right off the
bat there's really actually two main
problems that hit me immediately with
this setup one is when you put all these
together and you put them on uh the fans
which are in the ear cups start spinning
up and the air compressors turn on and
you can hear that because it's right on
your ear and so you're hearing that
through your music so you can kind of
drown It Out by turning the audio up but
that right off the bat was kind of
annoying but then the second is there's
no seal like you can still have air
passing over your nose and mouth but
things can also slip in above and below
even if it's close to your mouth so they
want you to have as little of a gap as
possible and it's adjustable so you can
shrink that visor down as much as you
want to basically have it touching the
tip of your nose but stuff will still
get in as long as there's no seal and
nobody wants to walk around breathing
from a literal tube like a scuba diving
mouthpiece so yeah this is just a
built-in flaw of the fact that nobody
wants that that's the way it's designed
plus there's a bunch of other quirks
like once the filtration gets going the
battery life goes from 50 hours to two
hours the visor is super light and
flimsy because it's completely plastic
presumably to be lightweight and keep it
balanced on your head but then it also
has all kinds of weird scratches and
poor finishes on the mesh and rubber and
plastic and just feels really cheap and
none of that none of that even touches
just how ridiculous you look and then
there's the pull medical problem so I'm
not a doctor but I do have a friend who
is Mike also happens to have a YouTube
channel you might have heard of him but
he explain to me exactly why this
product is even more flawed than I
realized on the surface yeah so I see a
product that actually confuses me more
than anything because I don't know who
the intended customer is because they
very clearly say this is not a medical
grade product there's no seal that
exists here on like a traditional n95
mask I look at the marketing material
and I see somebody out in a city in a
subway station and on the streets and
there's there's pollen there's smog
there's all kinds of other things and
they put this on and suddenly the air
they're breathing is clean they don't
smell or inhale any of it is that a
dream or am I missing something they say
that the product cleans up to 0.1
microns particles out of the air but
it's not HEPA rated because a HEPA rated
filter will actually filter particles
with a
99.95 efficacy it's not as good as an
n95 mask which has a seal and this is
where a lot of misinformation actually
spreads with n95 masks because when we
say n95 what we're saying is they have a
95 percent efficacy at filtering
particles that are 0.3 microns and you
might say well a covid particle is 0.1
Micron so does that mean they get
through n95 masks that's what some
people who are anti-master said right
most coveted particles that travel in
there are attached to things water
droplets respiratory droplets that kind
of thing so they're already bigger than
0.3 and they end up being captured by
the mask but they specifically choose
0.3 microns because when you go smaller
than that like a coveted particle at
point one it follows something known as
Brownian motion and this is where these
small particles move so randomly around
when they're dissolved in a gas like our
air that they end up being trapped by
The n95 Mask even better than the 0.3
okay there's a lot of things to why this
doesn't make sense I also saw a tweet
about how if you are specifically
thinking about covid and you are someone
who has covid and you wear this now when
you exhale all that air blowing is now
just being ejected out into space where
it'd normally stay in The Mask yes like
this device is not designed to keep your
air and your particles to your face like
a mask would yeah uh so what the company
has said in response to this that
there's enough room to wear a mask in
between but to me if you have room for
an n95 masks this eliminates the need
for this product because the n95 mask is
more effective at filtering the air and
creating a seal in this product so why
in the world would you wear a mask that
filters better than this and then this
thing on top of it but what I worry
about is it actually creates risk and it
creates risks in two ways one is that it
blows air directly onto your nose and
mouth which are your mucous membranes
anytime you have air circulating areas
that have a natural level of moisture
you dry them out dry mucous membranes
are a problem because they crack and
create openings for pathogen Center your
body then it's cold outside this thing
is blowing cold air at your mucous
membranes which actually causes
vasoconstriction meaning less blood flow
less white blood cells in the area
protecting you another problem and then
the real problem is I'm going to really
Hammer at home yes yes they say this is
like Urban environments where pollution
is high there's brake dust car pollution
all very valid all big problems we
should address
but in urban environments based on CDC
data
the rate per hundred thousand of debts
from chronic respiratory disease is
around 35. but you know what's 33
percent higher than that
unintentional accidents that goes up all
the way to 47 per hundred thousand yeah
and you know what's increasing rates of
unintentional accidents are you saying
that these noise canceling headphones
might actually cause more problems than
they solve yeah so why did they do this
Dyson is a weird company like I said at
the beginning they're they're a motor
and filtration company but they've had
so many hits they've made these Niche
products like stick vacuums and air
purifiers and hair dryers into like cult
favorites which is crazy I can actually
see how this product came to exist and
how it ended up being a thousand dollars
actually honestly
the thousand dollars part is the easy
part like when you just look at the
materials and the Cool Tech and the
packaging that went into this thing it's
kind of silly these headphones
themselves are super heavy but yeah
they're all metal the cups are metal the
bands are metal and there's obviously a
ton of tech in here the packaging is
hilarious there's not just the
headphones and the visor which look like
a smiley face but there's also a super
high quality carrying case with felt
lining there's a thick braided elastic
strap for that carrying case there's an
extra set of filters there is the
softest velvet headphone carrying pouch
I've ever seen there is a dual color
braided USBC cable with a headphone jack
adapter there's a metal airplane adapter
there's what I assume is a reusable
filter cleaner with a handle and another
carrying pouch for just the cables and
the accessories also super soft and then
there's this Dyson app that connects the
headphones that lets you not only change
the settings but also gives you a live
look at a summary of the air quality in
your area and then gives me a live
readout of the audio levels of my my
environment and how much sound the noise
cancellation mode is preventing from
getting to my ears I've never seen
anything like this with headphones and
like live real-time data visualization
like this gives you a summary of your
fan speed usage your noise cancellation
usage over time and gives you an
estimate of your filter life and a
direct link to buy new filters for once
you run out of the ones that come in the
box if you showed me all this repair
headphones and never even told me about
the filter thing or what brand it was
from I would assume that these are at
least 400 headphones but at the end of
the day most of this
like so many other things in the tech
world can be explained by
branding like it's only Dyson that could
have pulled this off and gotten this
thing as far as it has to get into this
video
but there's a sort of a term that you've
probably heard in the business world
before that a lot of companies use
called the loss leader strategy Barbara
Corcoran was on my podcast from Shark
Tank and she taught me about this
concept called Lost leader and basically
she believes that products that are
gimmicky in this vein will actually not
make company money but they'll draw
enough press that they'll sell other
products perhaps that's what's going on
they earn press yes yeah because there's
lost leaders that are like oh we can
afford to sell you this hardware for
cheap and lose money on it because you
will buy the software and make the money
back this one is a loss leader because
no one should buy it and probably no one
will but it'll generate enough Buzz that
people talk about Dyson we're doing it
right now and they'll be on them yeah
you win this round dice
here we are talking about your stupid
headphones with your stupid filter and
it's not you didn't even have to pay for
an ad like you wanted to so
yeah well played
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace